économie d'essence la campagne anti
gaspillage est ouverte là messieurs
bonsoir un acte de naissance en effet
pour commencer ce journal c'est un petit
bonhomme qui va bientôt être aussi
célèbre que bison futé ils ont
d'ailleurs tous les deux le même père
mais un petit bonhomme qui va avoir la
vie dure
il s'appelle gaspi et toute la france va
être mobilisée pour le traquer alors au
delà de ce gadget qui va surtout faire
sourire les enfants il y à une réalité
c'est la très sérieuse
les pays occidentaux et en particulier
la france consomme trop d'énergie
il faut encore en économiser sinon gare
au rationnement cette épée de damoclès
est toujours accroché au dessus de nos
têtes
chaque jour nous apporte un élément
nouveau qui sans nous affoler doit nous
faire réfléchir
aujourd'hui par exemple l'augmentation
du prix du pétrole au koweït et la
fermeture des stations service pendant
le week-end au japon
partons donc avec patricia lacoste à la
chasse au gaspi dans cette voiture
monsieur bison futé alias monsieur
pollitt directeur de l' agence pour les
économies d'énergie et polytechnicien
qui a inventé cette fois le gaspi
mangeurs de litres animal sournois il
faudra le combattre en suivant une
véritable carte de bataille distribuée
dans les stations service d'abord savoir
qu'est ce que ça prend pour voitures
consomment normalement quand on est un
chasseur débutants et ceux qu'elle
devrait consommer lorsqu'on est un
chasseur confirmé là pour ça nous
donnons des renseignements très précis à
tous les économistes qui peuvent savoir
ce qu'il consomme effectivement si je
prends l'exemple de la voiture que j'ai
ici c'est une simca à 308 gtb elle
devrait normalement confirmer si je suis
un chasseur débutants 7 litres 8 sur
route et si je suis un chasseur confirmé
je devrais arriver à consommer que 6
litre 4 c'est-à-dire 20% de moins pour
s'auto contrôler un indicateur de
consommation qui coûte pour l'instant
700 francs mais peut faire économiser 10
% d'essence
ordinateur dit calcul à tout instant la
consommation de la voiture à partir
d'une cabine c'est sur les carburateurs
et à mesure
une essence consommer et vous avez des
la consommation instantanée
je peux d'ailleurs vous montrer comment
elles d'harrison accéder en vous tenant
seulement à 5,8 dieu change de vitesse
il accélère de remonter rapidement après
ce titre valide ce qui montre bien que
la conduite sportive c'est très coûteux
et si je reviens ensuite une vitesse
plus normal jour descend des flics trois
jours d'essais à cette fille très je
vais retrouver sa cousine être inquiet
la consommation si vous venez à 80 90
kilomètres à l'heure sur le dos il y à
cette façon d'économiser du carburant
passer rapidement à la vitesse
supérieure en fait aller chercher le
plus vite possible
la carte est à une vitesse sur les
voitures modernes c'est la vitesse en
ville on peut très bien 50 à l'heure et
34e sans que le moteur souvent une
galerie non utilisé un litre aux cent de
gaspiller un gain de 2 litres au cent
surface de 130 à 110 à l'heure enfin des
pneus parfaitement gonflé actuellement à
près de là trois quarts des
automobilistes en des pneus qui sans se
gonfler
il faut respecter dépression recommandé
par les constructeurs
j'ai même si possible mettre 100 ou 200
grammes de plus ça permet d'économiser
centaines de grammes de carburant aux
100 km un moteur bien réglée pas de coup
de frein et d'accélération inutile enfin
un concours le plein le plus long avec
des prix de 10 mille francs
monsieur ministre est ce que le gaspi et
bien sérieux bien sûr c'est pas sérieux
l'austérité ne signifie pas forcément la
tristesse et les chiffres disent qu'il
en est puisque l'on économisera 12
milliards de centimes en devises pour la
collectivité et les automobilistes même
et que nous miserons s'ils suivent les
conseils 36 milliards de centimes
mais ce que ce n'est pas une goutte
d'eau par rapport à tout ce que dépense
l'industrie par exemple
bien sûr ce n'est qu'une contribution au
programme d'ensemble des économies
d'énergie c'est avec des gouttes d'eau
qu'on remplit les barrages
et c'est seulement par un ensemble de
mesures d'économie d'énergie que nous
réussirons à économiser et la quantité
qui est notre objectif
sans pour cela changer fondamentalement
le fonctionnement de l'économie de la
nation
il a un peu trop accéléré en tout cas
leur manière les ministres de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie réunis à
paris depuis ce matin chasse à leur
manière donc le gaspi le secrétaire
américain à l'énergie monsieur james
fait similaire vient de dire que tous
les pays du monde occidental se trouvait
dans le même bateau il ya aussi une
autre manière d'envisager le problème
qui d'ailleurs parallèle aux économies
d'énergie c'est la recherche d'énergie
de remplacement c'est que c'est un petit
peu la nodada antenne 2 à partir de
cette semaine nous allons passer aux
actes en vous parlant énergie solaire
chaque jour dans ses lavis et pendant
trois semaines
noël mamère nous fera vivre des
reportages sur des cas concrets ensuite
ce sera le journal de 12h45 qui prendra
le relais entre le 16 et le 22 juin
en allant musarder à biarritz à
collioure à montpellier à villeurbanne
et à sophia antipolis et à chaque fois
ce sera l'occasion de colloques
enfin deux points d'orgue d'abord la
grande soirée du 18 juin qui sera
réalisé dans le parc du château de
versailles et de jours à l'occasion de
vous reparler
sachez par exemple qu'on va créer pour
la circonstance une symphonie une
commande spéciale faite à jean rivier
par le ministre la culture et que le
directeur de la musique jacques
charpentier mettra lui-même la main à la
pâte en composant le générique de la
journée du soleil journée du soleil qui
verra son couronnement le 23 juin comme
il se doit avec dans des fêtes dans
quelque 300 connu le soleil voilà en
tout cas une denrée que l'on importe
avec plaisir et qui ne pèse pas lourd
dans la balance des paiements balance
encore excédentaires pour le mois
d'avril un milliard d'excellents on dit
au ministère du commerce extérieur que
ce mouvement favorable pourrait se
poursuivre jusqu'à l'été
un poste qui a en tout cas beaucoup pesé
dans l'un des plateaux de la belote la
balance l'industrie agroalimentaire une
industrie qui marche bien qui s'exporte
facilement regarder l'exemple du tout
les bretons qui sent les plumes bug à
toutes jambes vers le proche orient dans
le finistère 3 société d'abattage de
volailles les sociétés do thi ly et
bernard assure-t-elle 3 95% de
l'exportation française de poulet
l'une d'entre elles la société tilly a
été la première industrie
agroalimentaire a passé avec l'état une
convention de développement
elle s'est engagée à doubler ses
exportations d'ici 1981
en échange de quoi les pouvoirs publics
lui accorderont un soutien maximum une
initiative qui fait tâche d'huile
nous avons actuellement
le ministre de l'économie négociations
en vue de passer une convention
développement et nous sommes bien sûr
très intéressés ça nous permettra de
poursuivre notre plan de développement
et d'augmenter nos exploitations rythme
passé c'est à dire de l'ordre de 25 %
par an et nous espérons ça permettra
également de dégager ensemble de
financements pour les éleveurs à projets
dans d'autres abattoirs
car pour pouvoir augmenter leurs
exportations ces abattoirs sont obligés
de trouver de nouveaux éleveurs
pour ces derniers la construction d'un
poulailler comme celui ci coûte 500
mille francs
il leur faut alors être sûr de
l'utiliser au maximum pour le
rentabiliser les abattoirs des aventures
aux alentours chercher dit qu'il est
alors son show proposé de près du
poulailler
on m'annonce obtenu des contrats de
leurs premières secondes d'écoulées
parole comptera près sur sept ans c'est
dès 1960 que la vocation exportatrice de
ces abattoirs est né d'abord avec le
marché allemand puis en 73 le marché du
moyen-orient s'est ouvert avec la crise
du pétrole 70% de l'exportation se fait
avec l'arabie saoudite les émirats
arabes unis et le yémen du nord
j'ai 75 à 78 leur chiffre d'affaires a
presque triplé pour ces industriels la
recette de l'exportation est simple il
faut être le premier sur le marché et y
arriver en force mais il ya aussi la
concurrence et cela ne va pas sans
contraintes
les contraintes sont liées à la
compétitivité qui règne sur ces marchés
la compétitivité internationale est très
dur et très difficile et nous devons
tout d'abord avoir des prix nos produits
très bas dir est contraint dudit aux
transports les transformers itim vers
ces destinations pour le moyen-orient
n'existait pas il ne nous a fallu les
créer
sur le plan local le développement de la
production de ces abattoirs devrait
procurer encore de nombreux emplois dans
une région où le chômage s'est vite avec
force
actuellement ces trois sociétés
emploient 11 cents personnes et elle
prévoit la création de 475 emplois d'ici
6 981 indirectement ce devrait être 12
cents emplois qui seront créés en milieu
rural dans les trois années à venir
il y avait les poulets de bresse il ya
donc maintenant les poulettes brest un
mot encore sur l'économie pour vous dire
que raymond barre s'est rendu cet après
midi à l'assemblée permanente des
chambres de métiers pour présenter des
dispositions nouvelles en faveur de
l'artisanat pour vous dire aussi que
l'or a fait un nouveau bond sur le
marché de londres il a dépassé les 260 $
l'once et que le franc en revanche a
connu une légère baisse dans les
transactions entre banques la politique
donc maintenant avec tout d'abord une
nouvelle liste à prendre en compte
depuis ce matin elles sont déjà huit
avoir été déposée au mini salle
intérieure et ce n'est pas fini
celle là est composé et surtout conduite
par jean-jacques servan-schreiber et
françoise giroud qui ont donc choisi la
dissidence par rapport à l'udf tous deux
en kit d'ailleurs les instances
dirigeantes nom de la liste emploi
égalité europe
jjss veut en effet mener en priorité un
combat contre le fromage en 77
il y a deux ans des gens lorsque le
présent public m'a demandé ma chargé de
mission officiellement près de lui le
monsieur raymond bas la première réforme
que j'ai proposé c'est d'attaquer
massivement le chômage des jeunes est
une chose
intolérable et j'en ai définit les
moyens et monsieur parent a refusé et
depuis mon conflit avec monsieur bart
n'est pas un conflit de personnes
c'est le conflit sur le chômage ils le
considèrent comme une fatalité comme un
mal inévitable pour de longues années
je refuse cette fatalité et je prouve
que par l'europe avec une volonté nous
pouvons viser au contraire le plein
emploi
alors le règlement de comptes avec le
chômage et je le revendique le duel est
entre nous et le chômage est ce que vous
faites encore partie de la majorité
je ne sais pas quelle est la majorité ni
où elle est ni ce qu'elle veut comment
pourrais-je faire partie de quelque
chose aussi un défi nissent mme la
campagne européenne aura donc été
l'occasion de la rupture une rupture que
l'on voyait venir depuis longtemps déjà
en effet lors du congrès radical en
novembre dernier monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber et madame françoise
giroud avait très vivement critiqué la
politique du premier ministre
une fois de plus donc jean-jacques
servan-schreiber joue les trouble fête
la création de sa liste va je n'estime
qu'il a la foi l'udf et le parti
socialiste mais c'est vraisemblablement
la liste de madame simone veil qui en
souffrira le plus la cohésion de l'udf
n'est peut-être pas fondamentalement
mise en cause mais c'est un craquement
qui a tout de même son importance si
l'on se rappelle que monsieur
servan-schreiber a été l'un des
principaux artisans de la naissance de
ce regroupement au cours de l'hiver 1978
monsieur servan-schreiber fait état d'un
sondage selon lequel sa liste pourrait
obtenir entre 4 % et 14 % la fourchette
est importante il compte lui même sur
six pour cent
or vous le savez pour avoir des élus une
liste doit obtenir 5%
une fois de plus donc monsieur
jean-jacques servan-schreiber n'hésite
pas à prendre des risques
cette initiative de jjss provoque déjà
quelques remous la majorité des membres
du bureau du parti radical demande la
convocation immédiate de cette instance
et le président du mouvement des
radicaux de gauche
monsieur crépeau qu'ils jugent
malhonnête l'utilisation du sigle
émerger par cette liste tiendra lui une
conférence de presse après me quant à
l'udf elle parle dans sa lettre
quotidienne
idf1 d'initiative d'amertume et de débit
de dépit pardon faisant allusion au fait
que simone veil n'avait pas voulu de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber sur sa
liste passons notre chemin conclut l'udf
sans doute faut-il aussi attendent des
réactions supplémentaires ce soir la
part de nos deux invités au débat que
nous organisons conjointement avec
europe 1 jean-louis de seine et sur
place et nous présente la soirée
actuellement les participants patrick
sont en train de se préparer pour
l'émission spéciale qui débutera tout de
suite après le journal c'est à dire vers
20h35 une émission qui sera retransmise
conjointement par antenne 2 et europe
ce soir donc le sort a désigné françois
mitterrand et simone veil on peut noter
en passant qu'ils représentent les deux
listes qui pour l'instant arrive en tête
dans les sondages
monsieur mitterrand madame veil mais
attention il ne s'agira pas d'un face à
face entre les deux têtes de listes
européennes aux élections les deux
leaders seront interrogés successivement
pendant 40 minutes chacun par les
journalistes des deux rédactions
françois mitterrand d'abord le numéro un
de la liste socialiste sera questionné
par noël copain alain duhamel et daniel
grandclément dans un débat animé par
etienne mougeotte
puis vers 21h10 simone veil le numéro
de la liste udf union pour la france en
europe répondra aux questions de georges
bortoli gérard carreyrou et olivier de
reims un débat dirigé par jean pierre
elkabbach
à noter qu'après demain mercredi soir ce
sera le tour de jacques chirac et
georges marchais qui participeront à une
émission spéciale élections selon le
même dispositif
mais ce soir donc françois mitterrand
simone veil dans un peu plus de 20
minutes maintenant
à tout à l'heure ou plutôt à tout de
suite a tout de suite son sommet temps
aura peut-être d'ailleurs à coeur de
répondre à georges marchais qui tout à
l'heure a dit lui françois mitterrand
c'est l'échec permanent ils feraient
mieux d'examiner ses propres
responsabilités qui sont lourdes
cette petite phrase également de raymond
barre tout à l'heure annecy mais
l'adversaire non pas d'en tête le 10
juin mai 1981 les présidentielles il
ajoute que jacques chirac a lui aussi
déposé aujourd'hui au miss à l'intérieur
sa liste complète la liste défense des
intérêts de la france en europe et que
trois listes celle du ps eut celle
d'europe écologie et celle de région
europe protestent contre les inégalités
des temps d'antenne vu à sa manière par
gus voilà au delà de toutes ces
déclarations des uns et des autres il y
à l'enjeu qui n'est pas toujours bien
expliquée par les hommes politiques
aussi depuis une semaine avons nous
décidé à antenne 2 de vous dire les
choses
grâce à notre lexique sur les
institutions de la communauté
aujourd'hui le conseil des ministres dès
lors la commission constitue
l'administration de la communauté
économique européenne
elle est composée de treize membres
désignés pour quatre ans par les
gouvernements des états membres de
membres pour l'allemagne la france
l'italie et l'angleterre 1 pour les
autres pays
mais une fois nommé les commissaires
sont totalement indépendants et n'ont
aucun compte à rendre au gouvernement de
leur pays
seul parlement européen peut provoquer
leur démission collective en votant une
censure à la majorité des deux tiers
la commission siège à bruxelles où se
trouve aussi l'important corps
administratif qui dépend d'elle quelques
7000 fonctionnaires le rôle de la
commission est triple premiers rôles
elle est l'initiatrice de la politique
de la communauté dont elle exprime
l'intérêt face à ceux des pays membres
elle étudie et préparent toutes les
décisions du conseil des ministres et en
fait ces décisions sont le fruit d'un
dialogue
approfondie entre les deux institutions
sorte de courtiers la commission incite
les gouvernements à agir ensemble
deuxièmement la commission est gardienne
des traités et veille à leur bonne
application par les pays membres
elle seule a le droit d'enquêter de se
prononcer sur une éventuelle infraction
de l'un d'entre eux enfin dernier rôle
la commission exécuté décision qui
découle des traités ou celles prises par
le conseil
elle en établit les textes d'application
et en applique les mesures elle négocié
les accords internationaux et gère les
fonds de la communauté
nous avons donc mieux vu le rôle la
commission et non pas du conseil des
ministres le conseil des ministres c'est
pour demain soir et puis je suis encore
en matière politique valéry giscard
d'estaing célébrera samedi le cinquième
anniversaire de son élection à la
présidence dans le public dans une
petite commune du bocage vendéen la
rabatelière en fait le chef de l'état a
été élu un 19 mai mais n'a été
officiellement investie que le 27 mai 74
la rabatelière donc ceci dès son retour
d'afrique
il est pour l'heure vous le savez à
kigali au rwanda où s'ouvrait un nouveau
sommet franco-africain philippe rochot
nous décrit l'enjeu économique pour la
france et les 22 pays d'afrique noire de
l'angola à la côte d'ivoire voici la
nouvelle richesse des pays d'afrique le
pétrole la matière première qui fait
courir l'occident un symbole le nigeria
100 millions de tonnes par an c'est le
cinquième fournisseur de pétrole de la
france après les pays du golfe persique
nous lui achetons pour 4 milliards de
francs de pétrole par an et en échange
nous lui vendons des voitures ou des
biens d'équipement mais l'afrique nous
fournit surtout plus de 40% des minerais
dont nous avons besoin
ainsi le cuivre la ceinture entre le
zaïre et la zambie est vital non
seulement pour la france mais aussi pour
l'europe entière
quand on sait que la dernière guerre du
shabbat a paralysé la production et les
exportations
on comprend l'intérêt qu'a l'europe à
défendre cette zone et à soutenir les
chefs d'état en place
si l'on ajoute encore le faire de
mauritanie d'angola l'uranium du niger
on s'aperçoit que l'approvisionnement de
la france en matière première des pans
de pays politiquement instable nous une
aide militaire française en constante
augmentation chaque année pour empêcher
la déstabilisation des régimes africains
qui nous fournissent en matières
premières
le budget de la coopération atteint
cette année près de 3 milliards et demi
de francs
mais paris ne peut plus assurer seul la
réalisation de grands projets comme ces
barrages qui coupe les fleuves africains
la france doit d'y associer la
communauté européenne toute entière et
doit traiter avec tout le continent noir
et pas seulement les pays d'afrique
francophone
l'objectif de la conférence de kigali
est donc de trouver un véritable
équilibre économique non seulement entre
l'afrique et l'europe mais aussi avec le
monde arabe
3 casseurs du 23 mars passeront après
demain devant la cour d'appel de paris
il ne restera plus a jugé que cet
inculpé sur les 32 traduite en flagrant
délit c'était une affaire judiciaire
c'est devenu la semaine dernière une
affaire politique avec la prise de
position de françois mitterrand pour
leur libération immédiate
c'est en fait une affaire de société bon
nombre de nos confrères dont jean daniel
dans le nouvel observateur d'aujourd'hui
se sont interrogés sur le bien fondé de
la procédure de flagrant délit paul oui
padrixe et développement illustre bien
les réflexions les réserves même que
nous avions faite au soir de la première
comparution des reculs paix en chambre
des flagrants délits alors la procédure
de flagrant délit a été inventé je
dirais pour faire le ménage c'est à dire
pour éviter de maintenir en détention
par exemple un voleur à la tire et la
main dans le sac iphone qui fait du
tapage et qui cassent les vite le
bagarreur du samedi soir et c'est des
petits délinquants qui ont intérêt à
être jugé tout de suite mais qui peuvent
d'ailleurs demandé un délai de trois
jours pour préparer leur défense la
question se pose d'abord de savoir si
cette procédure de flagrant délit
elle était la meilleure pour juger les
manifestants entre guillemets arrêté
dans le dossier de la vinification du 23
mars le mac le parquet a voulu juger
vite sans doute pour répondre 10 ans à
l'étonnement sinon à la frayeur causée
par ces bagarres de rue ces
affrontements dont il ne faut pas nier
non plus les risques qu'il faisait le
courir aux passants et il est honnête
d'ajouter que ces mêmes magistrats du
parquet ont fait libérer n'ont pas
poursuivi plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants de personnes à l'égard
desquels les charges étaient trop minces
ou de carrément inexistantes
mais le problème dans ce dossier que les
témoignages d'identification retenues
contre les accusés provenaient tous deux
policiers chargés de maintenir l'ordre
on n'a pas eu le temps d'en chercher
d'autres de témoignages attention le
témoignage d'un policier vaut celui d'un
autre citoyen mais je crois que
l'addition des témoignages de ce genre à
l'exclusion d'autres qui ne seraient pas
partie prenante en quelque sorte ne
donne pas aux magistrats qui jugent sur
dossier suffisamment d'éléments de
réflexion
en outre on a pu constater à l'audience
que certains de ses témoignages
comportait des lacunes qui suscitait le
doute et le doute doit théoriquement
profiter à l'accusé même et c'est une
question de fond dans notre société dans
notre
justice actuellement même aux dépens des
intérêts généraux de la société
on accuse parfois la justice d'être
lente il ya souvent des risques à la
faire trop se presser il ya un fait des
faits troublants que nous examinerons
mercredi donc le jour de l'appel avec
nos reporters
le skieur de l'impossible vaincu par
l'himalaya deux de ses compagnons ainsi
qu un sherpa sont morts à près de 8000
mètres d'altitude emportées par des
avalanches et sylvain sedan et son
épouse ont pour l'instant les pieds et
doigts gelés
l'actualité sportive c'est
essentiellement ce soir du cyclisme avec
le départ du dauphiné libéré première
étape le prologue ou course contre la
montre qui a vu la victoire du
hollandais job sous de melt victoire de
justesse au et loire
48km 685 telle est la moyenne horaire
réalisé par le néerlandais york ajouté m
lors du prologue contre la montre cet
après midi à macau à prologue de 3 km 6
ans bernard hinault est deuxième à une
seconde et deux dixièmes
un écart psychologique pour ino mais qui
ne départage pas réellement les deux
camps les suisses lutter et 3e 4
secondes et m le critérium du dauphiné
libéré se poursuivra jusqu'à lundi
prochain avec l'arrivée à annecy foot e
mail casinos sont les deux favoris et
s'affronteront réellement dès jeudi lors
de l'ascension du mont ventoux
demain matin qu'on roanne première étape
209 kilomètres
une page cinéma maintenant nous
repartons pour cannes où le 32e festival
que ces derniers jours jean jacques
dufour nous propose cette fois un voyage
à travers une exposition d'affichés
réalisées par des amateurs du grand
écran souvent délaissée et pourtant
séduisante explicite ou parfois
trompeuses
la fille chine est mato graphique ne
joue pas un rôle mineur puisqu'elle
attire jusqu'à 30 % des spectateurs d'un
film elles sont ici à cannes partout
présente un hommage annuel que certaines
méritent largement s'étaient par
conséquent l'endroit idéal pour faire
découvrir un jeune garçon de 20 ans
passionné de dessin en lui décernant le
prix du 3e concours d'affichés pour son
travail sur le film
bref de singe il ya pas tellement de
recettes vous faites
j'ai cherché sur violette nozière qui
est un film à mon avis plus simple
querelle de singe mais j'ai absolument
rien trouvé c'est pour celui là que
l'idée m'est venue quand même assez
rapidement vous a mis du temps pour
réaliser cette affiche du temps
un peu plus d'une semaine ont fait un
pas loin d'une quinzaine de jours à
raison de six heures par jour de travail
mais dans ce domaine les créateurs ne
sont pas plus d'une dizaine autrefois on
faisait une affiche pour paris une pour
la province et une autre pour les états
unis
aujourd'hui les goûts se confondent et
on ne fait plus qu'une seule affiche
facturé de six mille à deux mille francs
selon ses dimensions ses oeuvres
originales ne laisse pas de droits
artistiques à leur hauteur fait pour
plaire d'abord aux producteurs
distributeurs il est nécessaire d'
exécuter quatre à cinq projets pour une
seule affiche est souvent les meilleurs
sont rejetés la majorité des affiches
mettent la vedette du film en avant
impact sur le public oblige mais parfois
quand il n'ya pas de vedette
une idée originale peut impliquer une
bonne recette le film de patrick
schulmann et la tendresse bordel en est
l'exemple le plus récent est le plus
fort on suppose que les gens qui sont
venus la première semaine sont presque
venus sur le titre et sur la fiche
puisqu'il savait pas grand-chose même
les critiques s'en sortir un petit peu
de retard et ça dure représentée je sais
pas l'attrait du jouet sur sur 5 200
mille spectateurs au départ mais comme
on en est à deux millions deux cent
mille spectateurs on suppose quand même
que le film après le les a séduits et
que c'est le bouche à oreille qui a fait
venir les jambes puisque le gym n'a pas
arrêté d'augmenter ses enfants à cannes
en période de festival
les affiches épis et se jalousent elles
attendent impatiemment les résultats des
délibérations du jeu
wii passe une petite bande blanche sur
laquelle est mentionné palme d'or en
c'est toujours plus élégant tout ça nous
amène la météo par le biais du seuil de
cannes aujourd'hui temps variable
c'est-à-dire alternance d'éclaircies et
de nuages avec quelques averses
sauf sur le midi ou soleil je vous
disais araignée demain moitié nord un
ciel le plus souvent couvert avec des
pluies
ailleurs temps nuageux avec d'assez
belles éclaircies
premier rendez vous de l'information sur
antenne 2 ce soir je vous le rappelle
dans quelques minutes spécial élections
européennes avec pour invité ce soir si
mon nouvel et françois mitterrand
d'abord en fin de programme pierre-alain
vous présentera le dernier journal vers
23h15 et pour terminer tout fait ce
journal une page musicale avec l'unique
concert ce soir à paris de michel jonasz
l'un des meilleurs représentants de la
chanson française de la cuvée des
souches ont aidé duteil et qui comme eux
est auteur compositeur interprète il a
ce soir pour nous a ajouté un autre
talent à sa palette
le journalisme pour antenne 2 et pour
gérard holtz il a joué les intervieweurs
il va interviewer c'est avec lui que je
vous type en vous souhaitant une
excellente soirée dont
e
m
et
grève michel jonasz et déjà longtemps
que l'an vous considère comme l'une des
valeurs sûres
voire même un des pionniers de ce que
l'on appelle désormais la nouvelle
chanson française ou plutôt à votre avis
si tu es michel jonasz au ca de ce
véritable mouvement aille non non non
pas de nouvelles chansons non je
comprends nouvelle chanson je vois un
nom pas de nouvelles chansons et un
poids de chansons inédites ya des
chansons du dernier disque weegee
beaucoup de chansons du disque du blues
du blues ou du tout une façon vous allez
voir pour une autre question
il ya deux ans michel jonasz vous avez
pris si je puis dire en main votre
création
vous qui jusqu'àlors chantier les autres
vous interprétez maintenant des chansons
dont vous signez seuls les textes et les
musiques votre personnage même à
semble-t-il évoluer vous faites
n'importe quoi bon vous a même vu tenir
un rôle comique dernièrement sur la
scène du théâtre de la gaîté
montparnasse avec la gaîté montparnasse
non non non l'olympia c'est l'olympia
d'ailleurs je vais vous présenter je
vais vous présenter les gens qui vont
participer uniquement là c'est un cas
exceptionnel si oui et michel curio et
la charger dit qu'il est denis lable
envie de clément bailly
tu vas me
guy delacroix gabriel yared attend si
vous voulez ce qui est extraordinaire ce
qui va se passer dans ses concerts et ça
je crois que ça s'était jamais vu avant
c'est qu'il y aura des gens dans la
salle il y aura des embrassades et en
plus y voir des éclairages une sono les
musiciens et un chanteur c'est moi oui
j'ai chanté avec un micro je sais je
sais c'est exceptionnel c'est fait
exprès un peu en question
ah non il a pu bonjour à gérard holtz
m
18 grève des poubelles que je traîne en
quartiers
jamais vu plus belle qu'elle
cité
mais serveuse du mil bas
du banana
des pilotes dans le noir
au cinéma
et
c'est rue pour la toux
baste et des cachots bonbons
machines à sous pour du tout superman
superman
non
zuber
super
et
tous les jours je football les boîtes de
bonbons
ces boîtes d'oeufs
tourner en rond
je ne
dans un prêche à la lie
au mont bacon
non pas
sur les dents
le
c'est le brésil comme ils veulent et
choucroute un bandeau d'art
douch
neige d'une à paris